yah hello and welcome to this video
the announced video on
the value of all the chess books doesn't
materialize today I still have this
problem with my neck I can barely move
it I don't want to sit here for too long
so just a couple of blitz games I also
hope that the technical side of thing
things that will work I this is a second
attempt to do this video I had one
couple of minutes ago and I had a
technical problem it doesn't happen so
often but my my computer it's a notebook
it's sometimes just a spontaneously goes
onto into hibernation mode yeah like in
the middle of a video recording which is
completely insane and yeah I don't
really know what to do about it I can i
tried things i cannot really figure out
how to stop it and get it super annoying
so this is a pretty nice variation for
white
um Dafoe is right I can never quite
remember these lines
I mean it's it's it it's well known for
a long time that black hair shouldn't
play like this but I keep forgetting why
exactly I mean I know h4g form and so on
but I'm oh it's uncertain about the mood
waters and the porn point is that Bishop
takes D takes Knight g4 fails to Queen
a4 check it become motive
yeah my method is h5 winning winning the
bishop
so no squares h5b should be for f3
this move I don't understand
that I had something great in mind but
why is that even a vague idea Queen a5 I
don't understand it at all
so afternoon
what is the trick
is probably no trick but
have to look
one thing that needs to be mentioned and
I have had this kind of position in
blitz games quite often they are still a
bit messy yeah whites King is open so
you always have to be a little bit a
little bit cautious that you're not I'm
running into some kind of meeting attack
now I can take here and then he's got
Bishop g3 but I don't think this is a
big deal
at the end of the day after I grab this
I mean he will probably take with the
night I guess he takes with the King I
take the bishop and they have Queen a4
immediately so Queen a for now we can
take and play Bishop c2 this is still
good for white but of course I'm taking
this and now I'm threatening Queen a4
just to simplify and this is just a
check I don't see
anything bad happening to me
yeah here you have to consider if I
could if there's actually more material
to be one or if I can just play Queen a4
I think just Queen a form um it's good
enough I'm just going to trade Queens
and
make sure that nothing bad happens to me
yeah Mok Ji Won
maybe politics before is still kind of
on but I have the check here and then
take a form
you know
and this is some basically
in the store uncoordinated kingside
position
- seven yeah right
about it
yeah just a piece right for absolutely
nothing
yeah so this is a bit of an opening
disaster I'm going to give him the
rematch
need to get some points back that game
when my kavita's went into hibernation I
lost I was actually able to continue it
because I mean it was hibernating it can
it work it comes back after like a
minute or so but I was so utterly
confused that could really get this
continue this I really don't know what
to do about this problem it's it's
extremely awful it doesn't happen often
but it's a yeah super super annoying so
with some weird move orders I'm getting
some sort of Kings Indian
not the best Kings Indian with the
bishop one evade
not not an ideal way to play
about anyway it's it's going to be
better for white
it's still complicated
how do we play him
you know it's got before you should play
this now I guess
otherwise 95 is a little bit of an
improvement for me I think you should go
before
you know now I'm going to take
go on c5 now
Stewart not very happy about all this
which was a bit of an experiment here
anyway
yeah I guess this is this I can actually
pre move
six I expect him to take on Poisson now
no this one
rising
you
how do we activate in this position
probably
mmm
you
okay I will never should go night a
night a to hear actually it's a little
bit odd but
let's do it
knight on c3 is certainly
night on before
you
I wonder if we hade is a move
yeah probably
yeah now Luke a3 I guess
maybe instead of Queen eight Hadoop
takes the tool
not the most intuitive north
so yeah let's just
drop back here
okay
I don't mind this all that much
I think age six next should be okay
where is he going with all this
six
even Bishop g4 was an idea it's not
quite clear where the bishop is going
now I am Bishop age 4 I have g5
I don't see why not you should be three
blunders the Queen YouTube Bishop g4
and I also have this rook a three move
this which is kind of kind of annoying
mmm okay now Bishop g4 or I also have
night h7 in some cases
get rid of the bishop I really want to
get rid of the bishop
take him I can also go here right this
is probably a bit bit bit better
should G four or nine h75 echo night age
seven I really want to play Bishop g5
if I'm
I can get rid of the bishop on his
heaven and my position should be
completely fine so taking this a problem
now I don't have a BEC rank
idea here unfortunately so let's go
Bishop g5
you know has to trade
context can be an idea
so check ito
it okay
the half-open age file can be and be
handy
so this one
lightly
bit of a clock disadvantage
you
now threatening g6
you
you know Weitz has some threads but
and it can easily get to a situation
where he has to move everything
backwards
you
all right this is something like that b6
look a seven
so my idea
Oh
I can take I had a complete I just I was
just uh this was just completely blind
and very much very much a shame because
it was it was I really liked the game
and white was honestly a little bit
outplayed down
I don't want to give up
okay I'm a queen down and since its
increment
but given how the game went I'm going to
continue a little bit
maybe he's making some more strange
decisions
you
I'm really difficult to screw it up even
if he plays really badly
you
our time is ticking down a little bit
you
now still fairly easy to witness
right
okay
you
yeah I mean a blunder for Queen if I
don't do that in my position I think is
pretty nice I really liked it how the
game went
Eric I was just completely blind and
somehow saw those pieces the other way
around
yeah so I just have to take then here or
I can I can also move the rook of course
I'm on the second rank but let's say if
I just take and play Knight f6 my
position is pretty okay
aking both here I'm not sure if I get on
the a file this is the thing that is not
quite clear to me
yeah this is just nice I got a Skype
message there like I don't know if I can
you just somehow anyway so let's go for
the next one um where are we going with
this yeah
that 60
um yeah I mean I haven't looked at this
issue in four months and then not going
to play it I will I will play it
yes III
one of the lines where I don't quite get
why people play that
in particular this one this is so so
utterly unambitious
I mean black equalizes so easily and in
some lines you can even argue that it is
that white has to fight for equality
okay
just taking this five is just week
night
yeah if five is just week why this this
is one of those cases where white is
fighting for equality okay I can just
grab you five does he have any sort of
compensation down
yeah it takes on d5 and then rookie one
so I'm just going to develop and see how
we will try to keep you five in the long
run there's going to be a liability no
matter what
when a four maybe
yeah of course I mean c3 is a the other
penis is somewhat is a healthy opening
it's not like it's terrible but I just
don't really see any danger like can
equalize with so many lines
until Wow
yeah this is a way to keep the e5 pawn
but it's also a way to weaken your
position tremendously
h5 armed is that is that a bit too much
come on
you
ship c5 maybe how do we
how do we get closer to the king
I take the bishop low take
then we should be quiet is it's pretty
strong actually it's a pretty good
position
just don't want to trade so much
okay let's do it
owning behind on the clock a little bit
you
it does trade Queens
yeah probably work t1 wants to trade
down the whole game and this is not so
precise
yeah yeah it was a bit of a problem
either had he five very weak or he had
to play this g4 stuff which is not
really what you want to do so it's not
challenging me and going for a new
opponent if they go for a rematch I will
usually accept
but
see or interest material is a very high
rating
very new account no like six
hundred games
you
you
let's see what we can do in this fashion
agafia
taking the time for these moves
surprising name
the start of theory
you
yeah one of the absolute main lines iam
g3 now is the usual continuation
this is the line I think we're on black
ass
I'm very reasonable chances to equalise
but of course why does some also quite
comfortable this g6 Bishop g7 is played
to actually allow nighty 7 later as long
as the bishop is on f6 97 runs into
night xf 6 gtx f6 and now I have removed
the bishop from the influence of the
night dome normally white plays Knight
III in this position one of the more set
come to mind and then I go 97
Bishop h3 is also an idea
not int
sure what I'm doing then you can also
play h5 there's nothing wrong about this
either I don't really have to be worried
or that much about the age file
usually like is not getting mated the
bishop on g7 is covering all the dark
squares I'm not getting made a damn bit
surprised that he's taking so long
thinking night is seven - right
let's see three now looks normal
take and then Bishop e7
this is a position that was played in
one of Magnus's games against Wesley so
against our bhangra this year not sure
it was starving and one of those
tournaments there are so many top-level
tournaments
the night cu3 TX takes I think the
capture was not played
Magnus in this kind of position I think
without the trade played Bishop e6 and
after Bishop h3 took on d5 um I have
analyzed oops it should be seven for the
fight like Magnus repertoire as an
alternative I think yeah this is what
I'm what I preferred I thought this is a
bit more active
case so what are you doing here I can
take care of it
okay
and evil
right
is that too early no I don't think so
again I'm not getting mated I just play
rookie aide and
yes just one single check which is
completely harmless
okay going for before here or I can also
play III here maybe I should go III
actually this is an opportunity that I
should not miss getting its came here
out out in the open and now what Queen
to b6 maybe
now why not
Andrew III looks completely
be smooth but this is also not bad huh
five also
possible
okay and it schnitz double No
you
okay queen to e3
invasion time
I don't really see how it coordinates
the skin G - I've got Queen d2
now I just wanted to go to f4 was my
idea
you
the check is also pretty strong actually
it should be - ivenn apiece
and here I thought okay to or something
should win okay to make eggs
kingi one there is no wind a bit of a
shame
you
22 he goes to g3
I just need to get in Bishop b5 check it
would be so nice
okay I don't see how and then let's just
play a normal-looking move this is
threatening Queen d2
um
[Music]
Bishop Bishop e5 first
you
I can't believe this this is still not
falling apart I must be a real really
must
trip she's seven mil
first I thought I blundered this but I
didn't
I don't see a window this is really
really frustrating Queen age 3 I don't I
still don't see you in
really remarkable
okay there is no win
you
I don't see when this is crazy
you
I do
deform
I mean
position is still completely
overwhelming of course but
thoughts should have been over for a
long time already but somehow it isn't
you
I cannot believe I couldn't find a mate
there it's really really weird
you
you
[Music]
he resigned I don't know why
it kind of mean it's kind of the result
that the game should have somehow but I
couldn't I don't know why he resigned
maybe had to leave or something
I can take g-form I'm just stupid here
just totally stupid
anyway I was I was really really amazed
that somehow this was going on
like you quint crew chief is just very
bad because this is just great for black
I'm activating my bishop here and his
bishop is bad so
I just I just couldn't find a win which
is extremely extremely weird
I was just like getting everybody
involved
a-five now given by the calm okay I'm
not playing this move that it's not a
move yet that I can play in a blitz game
I thought I should just win by yeah
piling up so to say but
yeah I'm actually not I plated quite
well not not too bad
there wasn't a complete killer it seems
and this is keeping everything
yeah I just keep my large advantage c8
was a bit better here but
for somewhere here there are winds yeah
Bishop d4 is a lot better our queen of
salmonids would have been very cute you
missed this one
and then you will draw pretty easily
have to play Bishop d4 okay yeah the
rook has no good square root gave one of
the state doesn't work and what are you
playing now if you move the rook
somewhere here you've got the rook
coming in
something like this so here he I could I
could and should have one and after the
trade I'm better but it's not clear that
I'm winning didn't even see that he had
blundered the part I could have taken it
yeah was little strange anyway let's go
for the next game
not
in very good shape
okay yet another Sicilian
a three
John
III is Grahame it splits a playable move
it's not maybe as strange as it looks at
first sometimes you can really get
something going with before
I just want to troll him a little bit
and it's not so bad I mean each form is
a threat why it has to react in some way
I don't think he wants to allow each
flock
it wants to lower age form
it's odd
you
to take I guess
okay
okay the F file is have open but
strategically speaking this is pretty
dubious
meda
or the squares you know II 5d form
permanently now under my control
[Music]
I mean okh takes also wasn't
particularly attractive but I still
would have probably preferred that
okay
Knight age 7
there is probably 95 of what is he doing
here
[Music]
a bishop doesn't have many squares and
there is sometimes Bishop d4 as well
you
Kim scrap this one
you
I wonder if I should check him here on
the forum King edge one
it's not not clear to me if this is
helping all that much
move like Bishop e6 is just nice AB if I
could Bishop h6 what what is he doing
then by the way
ninety-seven maybe the queen doesn't
have squares this is the idea
I'd see seven I can go can move the king
I was just basically thinking about yeah
why I'm better strategically and didn't
really think about concrete ideas and
this just seems to win the Queen Queen
age for there is a check only three
and denied c7 I go King d8
you
not Queen takes as then you can take the
bishop on g4
okay
[Music]
stick it
I think the check is probably strong
Bishop d4
it's a temple on the Queen and it covers
sook
should
Oh didn't see this more coming
Shinx
and then he wants to be one
you
yeah whatever
and now ya probably have to move the
rook
my book is hanging
you
Knight e4 maybe
No
wife
so it should be six
working the e farm
and my intention is to take on d5 and so
let's say Queen g5 I take D 5 and then
we need 7 1 97 is even stronger 97 and
then castling
you
it's a tempo and I really don't see
anything here I cookie five or so this
is just
not leading to anything at the end
you
I'm going to Castle queenside next
laughter move the bishop
or this one okay some didn't go for a
rematch
you
a mm-hmm I did I didn't have them
range
this is a fairly good line and you
sometimes really get night bt7
you could never never know
intermediate mate on f7
at the end of the day Wright has managed
to at least prevent the Bishop from c8
to freely develop which is one of the
key points of the Carol
so Christ here
I can take c6 here
why spaceship h2 somehow then an idea
[Music]
you
very weird
this one
you
my losing a piece after Bishop b5 57 you
cannot be serious
what
you
okay he's not threatening to take this
because Bishop takes b5 so I can
actually move this back
but Bishop b5 Bishop d7 I think I was
losing the piece that's crazy
and this is kind of
we should be seven
on takes or Queen takes Queen takes
actually attractive and the Queen is
pretty nice only five
Bishop g5 next
young 2g5 not clearly
helping me actually but okay ninety-five
Queenie for maybe
yeah I'm Queenie form he has to weaken
himself even more than
and that move I didn't consider actually
thought you had to go g6
you
yeah very very nice position now the
queen is fantastically placed on e5
and I can just play rook e1 and
pile up
okay
we have it how are we actually going to
win the game this is often an
underestimated question now that you
have to ask like this is a nice position
but how exactly are we going to enter
and the whole thing
this is so
[Music]
so obvious we have six No
to go back
you
you
yeah Zone B 3 C 4 maybe
I really thought you should have stayed
on g6 why didn't he do that
that at least looks like some kind of
activity
you
[Music]
yeah kind of two trades
not sure
what's best now queen g3f for doesn't
really help them
I'm really happy that I have the e4
square now now I can buy rookie for
rookie 1 and pile up
95 I always have c-form
this is mostly weakening like I think
roll
I should at some point play this move to
not get back rank method
just it's not really urgent but
it will be useful
now I should ultimately try to
open up the position and see if I can
checkmate him here with d5 coming there
should be possible so would be five if
he takes us Ruby seven
it should be a pretty devastating
I don't see
any sort of counterclaim the immediate
threat I believe is rook checks six
rook takes Knight takes c6 rook takes is
six screen b1 check in h2 and then I'm
threatening all kinds of things Queen g6
made taking on age six
not really a defense I think
just repeat seven
where is the mage don't see a maid
you
you can actually pull off Queen h6 made
yeah so I was a bit of a bit of an odd
game particularly b5 was pretty shocking
I just say what's the point yeah I just
take and then yet Queen b6 that that was
really remarkable
[Music]
hmm yeah
this is just just crazy it seems that d5
is possible an idea that I did not see
the point being okay this is difficult
to see the point being that after Knight
takes rook t1 Bishop c6 this rook t5
because there are all kinds of weird
pins going on I didn't see that I was
happy that I spotted Bishop d3 now if he
would have played castles 95 24 Black is
completely okay which is really strange
okay now um let's see
like one or two more games maybe
we rated the river
reaching floor
you
see
taking a [ __ ]
I really like to have the increment like
in general but in particular if I don't
if you don't feel that fresh you don't
want this crazy scrambles at the end
Knapp Cellini our carrots County form
yeah g3 is my standard repertoire wolf
and we're now heading into a Catalan
take
you know here black has a wide choice c5
Bishop d7
yeah 96 is not so great but not not
terrible either
57 is the main booth but people also
play c5 quite a bit
a b5 is the currently fashionable line
but it's just the kind of line that you
only play if you absolutely know it
just it's a pawn sacrifice
[Music]
I really should study this
it happens pretty often in my games and
I always wonder what
was I what the most precise move
actually is because many things look
good but not so easy to determine what's
what's best
I expect the capture okay Bishop d7 is
also
Moo's chef g5 though looks a bit
[Music]
you
before it's surprising
you
yeah I know the night doesn't look great
I'm more of a liability and my night
only five is extremely strong
let's see how he decides to untangle
now here I can take or I can go Bishop
g5 this also
it's going out to Sarah
I can never be bad let's say and um
as you move to play you could see one
now intending to
six
he wants this position with G takes
maybe this is not too bad actually now
that I think of it
it seems that he doesn't mind to take
with the Jeep horn
if I take c5 fiyaquun' shakes that's
something that I can do them
no it's not
obvious at least
okay so let's take and give him that
double pawn queen takes this rook c5
takes some more or less forced and not
bad it's not really bad for him
okay why is this why is this a
consideration so take him
you
making beef form the incorrect queen
sacrifice
maybe you'll see four
be a little bit cautious that I'm not
running into some Bishop f2 tactic
propose a take back but
Brooksie a rope dat blonde oh I didn't
see it
I usually don't give take backs
unless it's a su it's a super obvious
mouse lip
[Music]
No
you
you
now I don't have anything absolutely
absolutely not
preparing III with the smooth
have a 33 square
you three and 94 I don't think he's got
any particular problem yet oh I can go
I can this is a very
a conservative way of doing it but it's
not bad
just keeps everything nicely covered
maybe I can swing the rook over to
reform
okay
not happening
[Music]
McQueen is not really great
I would really like to
get the Queen over
93 I don't mind
three
I like to have the night here against
the bishop
you
this is not actually or they're
dangerous
for I just want to have some
we'll get form
point
now
you
yes it's 95
I'm not sure that I'm actually getting
something here
you
you know I can take and then go rook h1
25 hooked reform
maybe roopd true
oh okay
tikkun cheeks
and it's to it
wind shakes I don't really have anything
great here only enough
you
don't see anything bad happening to my
king queen h5
you
12 seconds so I'm not losing one time
bitte oven
increment boost
and F what is not great
Oh
so how can we win
probably still with some f4 business
three and then go from there
[Music]
you
I still go back now maybe f5
you
not sure if this is right
you
rook g8 mate was the idea
you
eight seconds
you
you know it's also difficult technically
complicated game I mean
if somewhere here I maybe had something
better
it always looked like a little something
but probably k92 seems to be stronger on
IG for now g4 is something I could have
seen that's not it exactly difficult
giving them the double porn because this
is really not not much
requested a take-back here I don't know
maybe was a miss click I don't know if
it wasn't a blunder and somewhere and
here I think it's just as the engine
displays this is equal him
I tried this G for business ok here five
not such an easy move to make
life
ideas to play eform black yeah I don't
really have a good reply to that often
this move would be too loose because of
their five porn being so weak like
something like this but it's just too
quick iam
this is just not working
hanging
strong
ium this is again it's probably about
equal
it's possible that somewhere here they
were part of them there was something
okay now we had roopd to walk him after
way Quincy to
we were both in quite some some time
pressure here
cringe on the g5 was strong for Quincy
226
yeah it was probably very shaky around
him okay so I think one more game and
then I really have to
this
you do some
neck again BBP 55
you know
I had a game against this player some
days ago which are lost don't quite
remember
what the game was
stating
I played a BOGO Indian haven't done that
or quite a bit
this is not going to be a brilliant or
black but
to have this typical
dog whinnying pawn structure played this
kind of
structure for a while
angling for 95
being very quickly
Jim
you
yeah I'm thinking for a little bit
because I have a technical possibility
here with Knight takes e4
yeah this looks okay right
fifty-three ago e-form
and the resulting position should be a
pretty okay for me
at least
you
I didn't hear can just take
five I mean pairs wrong if he canceled I
go Bishop f5 is what I'm trying to say
this looks hard to believe really
you should f5
reddening III looks very scary
maybe that wasn't even the best move
yeah I really hope to level the score
against BP 55 the otherwise okay just
resigns I mean I'm not quite sure what's
best Queen age for I mean it looks
devastating many moves 93 as well okay
there was a really really short game so
one more then I'm going to call it a day
our results are actually quite okay
I feel very fresh but
today we saw a gay Mia Restless so
against Hikaru Nakamura in that Tata
Steel India event
Hikaru took on the forum but it seemed
that Wesley did not
it's not own my keep it simpler default
course he didn't really play it well
afterwards
and got into some trouble
[Music]
it looks very accommodating
am I just going to go for the pawn and
with what to move probably just 95
it's not so clear how he's getting
this back visit
now Kim
you
hmm very strange something-something
probably did something wrong here
that doesn't look that good
you
yeah I don't know I don't see anything
good I have to see 60 it takes with the
night
you
you
should be 395
maybe I have to play this you know and
we should before
very odd
I didn't think of the smoo at all okay
it's not bad what
what on earth
and it's it's crazy it's just like
dashing this outdoor all immediately
okay both nights are hanging and my rook
is singing
okay so b1 maybe
you
[Music]
you
difficult move Europe takes you five I
have to think about this first
you
I don't really have any substantial
counterplay he unfortunately
you
let's cover this maybe I'm still getting
I'm getting c2 somehow
you
mhm
doesn't look like you know e5a strong
move
should
no the look h2
you
okay yeah there are some games where you
feel hmm yeah whatever you do them it's
odd
so he plays this really weird weird
opening line where he and develops the
night and then like here Luke ca
displayed
and now if he plays 94-96
and takes between which is super obvious
of course
and Jim
you
Jim I don't know
I have to improve
was somewhere probably 95 is wrong
jiwon seems to be more precise
Jim you can draw your own conclusions I
say I hope you enjoyed the session I
hope I can do this book themed video
tomorrow I think I can it's getting
better by the day
um and then I feel more comfortable for
a longer time here at the desk I'm going
to do the video thanks a lot for
watching guys bye bye